Tan you were here to talk about your
latest film hysteria now it's a rom-com
about the invention of the vibrator set
in Victorian England when a friend of
yours who the producer came to it the
idea what was your first reaction I
laughed I felt was the funniest thing
I'd ever heard and I said I want to see
that movie and since no one had made it
i thought i should make the movie so
that was it and you gave everyone a
little present on the set i heard how'd
you find out about that um yes i gave
everyone a vibrator as a welcome gift I
just thought it was fun and jokey and
whatever and our gaffer a very sweet guy
British guy I didn't know what they were
cuz they were kind of multicolored than
about this big and he goes oh can I have
a pink one for my daughter and everyone
was on a reccy on the bus and I was kind
of like wow Ryan okay and his friend who
was our makeup um kind of chief hair and
makeup said do you know what that is
because I was lipstick so you can tell
it was really small that's a great story
I and you've always got a great cast in
the film haven't year the first person
on board was actually jonathan pryce
wasn't he yeah you did yeah it was a
dream cast and it's just one of those
things where we kind of wrote our top
five for all the roles and everyone was
kind of in the you know well at least
topped up it was it was insane but it
took a while and so getting we just kind
of got the script to whomever we could
get two on the list and Jonathan was the
first one who actually read it and
responded and I think it took about I
don't know we had a coffee nose drinks
drinks was important actually um for two
hours and one of my producers came along
and about an hour and a half into it he
looked at me and he goes well I think
you're both mad but sure so and then it
just took a long time to kind of get all
the finance together as it's always the
case with these films yeah and he plays
a doctor in the field is a huge reits
women in Victorian Britain and for
hysteria and he has various methods for
doing this no one of them resulted in
Jonathan getting a bit of an injury on
thur didn't he tell me about that yeah
well so um hysteria right is this kind
of fictitious all fictitious catch-all
disease
for kind of the condition of being a
woman and luckily one of the nicer
treatments i think was massage to
paroxysm and which you know i mean
actually sounds like a fun time at the
dr the city not to see me and sleazy but
so Jonathan you know I was kind of like
how are we gonna I knew I wanted to
shoot it because I knew it was funny was
the doctors just seemed very like oh god
takes forever and i'm at work and I'm
bored I didn't think of it as sexual
because since it wasn't about a man's
sexual pleasure obviously no one was
having any fun from their point of view
and so we're still trying to figure out
the mechanics of how we are going to
shoot it in terms of making sure that
their body language looked right because
obviously they weren't going to be um
what do you say here touching up the
actresses I don't know if that's okay to
say okay all right um I kind of throw
all the lingo around I don't really know
what's appropriate sounds pretty
American and so we had to figure out
something for Jonathan and hewed a
massage that wasn't an actress but was
near an actress and so Hugh very wisely
after a lot of really inappropriate
suggestions mostly for me not up to him
but never um you know he just said we'll
look there's lots of sandbags holding
down the light so we'll put that down
and one of them a very rough surface and
so Jonathan I was vigorously getting it
apart and he rubbed like the skin off of
the knuckles I wanted was bankers and
had to get like you know someone to come
on set and do a bit of first aid and
bandaged up is poor raw finger suffering
free thoughts exactly very serious takes
it seriously you guys aren't even method
actors over here and you mentioned he
doesn't see there how did he come and
become involved in the film you know
it's funny because I had seen his film
work and then I saw him in a play that
of course was a play that it transferred
from here to New York called journeys an
you know famous play and he was so
brilliant and you think well that is
such a serious play but I just I went oh
when I saw that he can do anything and
it was tricky finding that kind of
30-something earnest male who's a
clueless but still very masculine that
you know it was kind of the kind of new
hugh grant in a way but I don't know if
you if you would like saying that
because Hugh's his own you but um you
know we kind of said okay we want that
young bright-eyed guy and it was just
really interesting aren't a lot of
actors around who could kind of do the
comedy and do that I'm really serious
acting work that it takes and so he's
one of the few and talking about
versatility and people can just do about
everything maggie gyllenhaal core she
have a solid lead actress and there she
is fantastic isn't she had not only
issue great actress but she's got a
flawless British accent again and this
isn't she yeah she's she's just I mean
we said who's the next Catherine
happening Katharine Hepburn god I can't
speak anymore yeah so um we were looking
around for you know Katharine Hepburn
but I mean when we were kind of coming
up with it the writers were riding it I
mean Maggie was something we always
talked about so it was like you know
when a dream date with you know it was
crazy said we are very lucky I'm casting
and I think it's all you know between
the team the design and the photography
and all of that and then the acting and
I mean it made my job a lot easier and
young rising star and Felicity Jones as
well and you got her before I think like
crazy didn't you yeah yeah it was very
very lucky it was a tricky role to
Cassar lots of good actresses but no one
who just walked in and I you know when
when Sheridan Smith walked in i said ok
were casting her like I didn't even do
we have to see anyone else um but
Felicity had been off shooting something
and so I'd seen a lot of really good
actresses because you guys seem to have
like a special something kind of magic
potion you give your actors in their
training and they all turn out brilliant
but no one had found just the kind of
you know you kind of don't even know
what you're looking for after a certain
point you just need that special
something and gabi kester and my casting
directors it's like lovely a kind of
woman just been you know worked on tons
and tons of great films and this is her
first one is the lead cast Murphy she's
a chest hold off there's someone I want
you to see and it's been tricky and I
know we're late into pre-production but
you really need to see this this woman
and she walked in and I went oh ok done
you know and so is
good cuz I think that's how you get a
great cast you don't just kind of cuss
when you can kind of do the job someone
who shows you that the job is something
different than what you thought really
and he's mentioned Sheridan Smith no
smile and I believe you actually saw her
in Legally Blonde and that's when you
thought yes I want her in this film yeah
you know it's funny my producer said oh
you've got to come see this actress and
legally blonde the musical and I was
like oh I like the film and I do like
musicals guys but maybe it's to camp and
we were trying to not be so broad we
were trying to kind of find our way
somewhere between you know kind of
dramatic costume drama and you know
seaside postcards like somewhere kind of
down the middle there and she said got
to see this woman and I went to the
theater and I was like what who's that
she's you know it's crazy she's crazy
talented i really want to find something
you know i love devon something for her
and Felicity like a two-hander something
really fun but she can actually condense
she can sing she can do comedy I mean
she's beautiful it's ridiculous she's
you know I feel like I'm gonna be one of
those people who said God thank God I
got to work with her when same with
felicity really same with all my cast I
just feel fortunate and a little role in
there as well for a couple of amorous
ducks and I believe they cause a little
bit of trouble getting footage of them
you got to tell me a little bit about
that you did your homework dad was
needless to say ducks do not shag on
command and him them and I it took a
long time ultimately we had to get there
was like some Scandinavian naturalist's
who shot the footage we ultimately used
but I had you know crew members in the
field on weekend yeah literally I have
hard drives full of duck porn so that'll
maybe beyond the DVD extras i don't know
if i don't get arrested and next via
believe you've got a big biopic coming
up
I can't tell you but it's a British pop
star of yesteryear that's it that's all
I'll say and a really wonderful lead
actress who everyone knows but how much
yes to you before now was that what I do
not alive now i will say that well we'll
have to talk about that another time I
celos a look at that and lots of luck of
course with hysteria which opens in the
UK this week as well thanks very much
the speaking test on you very much
you